Hmm.
Good afternoon, Karen. How are you?
Hello, good. How are you?
Saying good, good.
She is.
Think I'm not sure from ITBD. I'm only the one who's going to join the interview. Oh, sorry, the call, but yeah.
I assume Aleks will be here.
How's everything going?
Oh, it's going pretty good. And you?
Yeah, same here, busy, busy day.
Sameer and I were working on a...
ticket involving, you know, sending a tech out to a client. So that was interesting this morning.
Oh, okay. So you're you interact with all the engineer, right?
I guess.
So, how you been found summer as of now?
I think he's doing very well, he.
He put in a work order for us, you know, and I reviewed it. I mean, not that I know that much about it, but I reviewed what I could with him and told him what Aleks did and did not want in it and gave him a previous work order that was for the same thing. So we took a couple of things from that as well. But he did very good.
I think we're we're growing. Team is growing. We have Saf with a new person going to onboard tomorrow, so I think.
Is it tomorrow already?
Yeah.
I didn't know when he was coming on board, but I saw the invoice for him. The initial invoice, yeah.
S.
Yeah.
So, and I think we have, I mean, we were discussing yesterday, but now we have like a stronger team, all the layer we we build up, starting from Shivani, then Vincente, then you know, Animesh, now on the top, Saf, you know, yeah, I think he's working almost 7.
Seven, 8 year in ITBD, and it's a good experience in working on SME level.
Good.
So, of course, Kaila.
Get us benefit.
Actually.
Yeah.
We spoke yesterday almost, I think, 33 minute.
We're discussing about how things going to be and what going to be the plan for all the engineer.
You and Aleks.
Yeah.
I'm just getting some clarity about the new shift changes. So that's where we discuss about how things going, what all the things we are looking to change, you know, implementing, how we're going to make the process better.
I forgot about the shift change.
Yeah.
And how are we going to utilize everyone get most of the benefit out of their skill set, their expertise to, you know, the dad value at your side?
I just sent Alex a message to see if he's joining.
Hey, hello.
And so, I'm not sure you were invited on.
There was another we were discussing yesterday about the...
Cube, here we go. Hey.
Hey, we got a QBR coming up in at 230. That's right. We were about to say that.
Yeah, I was checking this morning with Rick as well, right, just by log with Amit that what our plan because we have our service call and I think I was I checked with you yesterday that you were not aware about that we have a QVR, so how we are planning, you know.
We are planning a QBR at 2.30, is that right?
Yeah.
Yes or no? Yeah, that's okay. Okay. All right, good.
Yeah, so no, no, I mean, I...
Yeah, look, I just typed up a couple of quick notes, but you know what your QBR make it system or whatever the case may be, I don't know, but
In A nutshell.
So have you done any QA prior to this or?
Yeah.
No, no, I don't think so. You know, we were we were in a bad in bad shape about, I would say, March.
You know, March or April, I think we hadn't had Vincent on board yet. We didn't have Vincent Summer, you know, and obviously Safe coming on board on a mesh. Yeah, basically not, you know, all four new, right? The only person that was, you know, here was Shivani at that time.
Yeah, and and an image.
Shivani.
We were basically, yeah, we were in an emergency state trying to get hires from you guys because we were not getting where we need to go. And so, you know, this is our first QBR. You know, I think I'm going to stress basically, you know, I typed up a couple of notes which I was trying to assemble just a moment ago regarding
staff roles, you know, I will provide you all and everyone more and more and more documentation. You know, I'll repeat, I'll repeat the same thing. So as you could see, I added you to a chat.
with the Shivani. I mean, I could send you screenshot after screenshot after screenshot where time entries aren't being done, calendars aren't updated. You know, nobody's, and let me explain why this is important, because people can organize. They suddenly, they're lost. You know, they're like, oh my gosh, what do I do? What do I do? Well, if you are,
Making sure you can organize your calendar and your tickets and your schedule, you will make sure you will be able to get everything done. And you will be able to communicate with every client that you're communicating with. I'm not giving anyone too much work. Everybody needs to make sure that
They are.
you know, understanding their tickets. It's their tickets. You very quickly can look at your board and sort tickets on your, you know, whether assigned to you. So, you know, I just think that there's a little bit more, and the way that I can't be told, like, in a ticket, oh, I'm working with this person. Okay, well,
Why is your calendar not reflecting that you're working with this person? You know, why is your, why are your time entries don't exist for the entire day until one in the afternoon? I have these conversations with tech after tech. The good techs don't have a problem with this. Okay, they are able to handle it.
You know, so this is going to be the point that I'm going to stress continuously, you know, especially with the larger team. There's 2 things that are going to happen. With a larger team, it gets to be a bigger problem when this stuff is not followed this way.
Yeah, right, I guess, yeah.
Second problem we have is all of the people in one space, right? Again, too much talking and not enough process. It has to be process based. So if, you know, like Summer told me that he took a ticket today, that Animesh had assigned to him yesterday.
that no, that that Animesh had assigned to himself. It was an Animesh ticket. And I go ahead and say, okay, please update the ticket. And then I get a Teams note that Summer is working on it, but Summer's not even on the ticket. And then he closes the ticket and then nobody put a time entry in the ticket. And then he tells me in a Teams message that Animesh asked him to do, I don't know what happened.
Yeah, yeah.
But the point is, it wasn't in ConnectWise, right? So everything has to be in ConnectWise. Okay, who's doing what? Who's assigning what? If Anamesh can't do it, why can't he do it? If it was his ticket, is it getting, if he gives it to Summer to do, that's fine. Just make sure the ticket is updated, that now it's assigned to Summer.
And greeting.
Summer is the ticket owner. You know, this all goes constant. It's going to be a constant thing. So I'm going to rewrite the manuals that we have. You know, when people say they know how to use a ticketing system,
Right, but they don't do any of these things.
Yep.
They don't know how to use the ticketing system.
No, hi Aman, whatever the conversation for last month or you know that we are ongoing, what I observe is that the real time entries, it's not only the other, I have another team for right 12 people, so they follow the same practice. They have started working on the ticket, put a ticket in progress, update that notes while you're talking to the customer.
Yeah.
right, everything on your calendar. So they are sitting on a different side or different place. Even I don't need to go to walk up and talk to everyone that what all you're doing. I only can go to connect by see that what ticket they're working, if the real notes are updated. So it's not that they worked on the tickets. So what gap I also noticed. So I have already started working on it. I mean, they started working on a ticket.
They work maybe 10 o'clock. They're putting notes at 11 o'clock, right? So that's not matching the time when you call the customer and the time. So it should be in a real time basis. And while you're talking to working on a user, just update the notes side by side. Start typing your notes. This is what I've done. This is what I have done. And that way you have the real.
time visibility as well and you know everything is on time.
Yeah, like, like you saw my little note to Shivani. I was like, okay, I actually, I saw the ticket because I look at the board. I'm doing other things, but I can see things. If they pop up on the service board, I say, oh, well, this customer responded. I see the bold print. Karen sees it. Karen sees these tickets, but they don't even belong to me or Karen, but they belong to Shivani or they belong to Vincent and they belong to Summer.
Yeah, that.
No.
Atul.
It belonged to Anamesh. So you see, okay, I see the response. I'm like, okay, what's going on? I click on it.
Okay, 1215 customer says, hey, I can work with you today between 1230 and one, you know, but then there's, I look at it, I don't say anything. I just let it sit there. I go back an hour later. I'm like, oh, well, still nothing. No response to the customer, you know? And then she says, oh, well, I was on the phone with
So, just one.
I was working with Dean. Okay, but your calendar doesn't show that you're working with Dean. Your calendar's empty. How can you tell me you're working with somebody when it's not even on your calendar, that that's blocked out? And we have these conversations every week. The conversation, it's a positive conversation, right, Karen? During the team meetings, I'm not getting on anyone individually. I'm saying,
Exactly right.
Right.
Yeah.
These are the processes. This is how you're supposed to do things. And now you hear me in a frustrated tone because I'm like, I've repeated this over and over and over, you know? And then somebody says to me, oh, again, oh, I was working on this. Okay. Or I was busy. Okay, why is your, if you're busy,
But there's your calendar's empty.
How can you tell me you're busy? You know, so it doesn't make any sense. That stuff makes no sense. It's not acceptable, really, you know, right?
And related to this real example that we have, I think, yesterday about Summer, right? I mean, he was on a lunch, right? But it was not in his calendar. So you were not aware that he's on a lunch, right? So you put an invite for a meeting, then he was unable to join. So if it was in his calendar, of course, you were aware that he's out.
Yeah.
So maybe the time could be definitely different, you know.
Right.
Right, right, right. That's an example, so...
Well, that all in my priority list, right? To keep eyes closely, to figure out, to make sure these missed, everything is on real time basis, whatever they're working, it should be on their calendar. It's not like someone stuck on one issue, they just reach next to, oh, you can fix it, but the time entry is not there, you know.
Yeah.
So what I try to do is I try not to micromanage, right? Like I try not to get into micromanage. So because I don't expect everything to be perfect, right? So I never want staff, you know, the team to feel like I'm more looking over their shoulder, like all day looking for mistakes, because that's not what I'm doing.
What happens is, well, when I see the divergence, when I start to see everything fall apart, then I'm saying, oh my gosh, I got to get in here and talk to everybody. Because I've told them many times on meetings, I'm like, I understand if you get busy, something goes wrong, but you got to get back on track. So, you know, it should, at the end of the day,
It should absolutely reflect more accurately, you know, what did you do today? Whatever. I do, I try to do things as real time as possible, right? It's easier to update the calendar. Sometimes it's harder to update the notes really quickly, but then you should update the notes before you work out and then, you know, before you finish.
Another ticket.
You can't move on to the next thing until you've updated your notes on the existing one. And then, you know, completed what you need to complete on that one. You need to do the customer facing notes, right? Those got to be done. So the customer is updated. When you had a phone conversation, you updated the ticket with a ticket note. Summer's actually seems to be, Summer means seems more familiar with that than anybody. Summer's really good at that.
Yeah.
Vincent's really good at that. Shivani falls off. She's often falling off of the, you know, and she's one of the most important ones because she's doing a lot of customer facing. So, and she's always the first person to touch a ticket. So it's more important for Shivani to be as accurate as possible because she's the first person touching a ticket, right?
So, you know, you know, that's why it becomes, you know, a bigger issue. If it's a more complex ticket that's going to take multiple days, I try to put it to different boards. It might be an implementation ticket, it might take two weeks, three weeks to do implementation. You know, so those are different types of tickets. But if there's a customer reporting a problem like Dean did, he's like, Monday, he sends us a note, Monday.
Right? He says, I have a problem. And then Shivani didn't get back to him at all. Nobody getting, nobody got back to him. There's no response to him until I said something today in the team chat to you and Karen in that chat. I said, well, you know, what's up with that? So
So it's very, it's a little confusing to me why we're having problems. I think, I don't, I have confidence we can fix them, fix the problems. Also, I noticed like summer,
Summer earlier today, tried to assign Shivani, like they want to use Shivani like a secretary, but she's not a secretary. So like, it's not Shivani's job to work on something that might be a hard drive replacement. I said, okay, because I want to make sure we stay flat. You know, owner of the ticket, handle the ticket, you know, it doesn't all become Shivani's problem. She's not a coordinator for everybody, right?
So like Summer's working on a ticket for a hard drive replacement for a server. It's his ticket. Nobody else needs to be working on it. He works on that ticket. You know, you know, he's working with HPE. He doesn't need to put it on Shivani's schedule or anything. So I took Shivani right directly off of that when I saw that.
Yeah, good.
And I updated the ticket and explained why Summer needs to handle it. And it's his ticket, and you know, he's the owner on the ticket. You know, so we use these fields. And I mean, I don't even get on, I don't know if Gary can remember back in the day, I used to get really like, okay, you got to pick the right role.
the right, you know, role, work type, all of these things I used to get out. I'm not even asking for that. I'm just asking for calendar entries, time entries, you know, ticket owners to be owners, follow-up appointments for all the tickets. So anybody who has a ticket there, there's a follow-up appointment. As soon as you are done touching that ticket, your next appointment should be in the ticket.
Oh.
so that it comes up automatically. It shouldn't be in your brain. It shouldn't be on a list somewhere else. It's just in the ticket. Your next time is in the ticket so that, you know, automatically it'll show up on your calendar when you need to touch it back. So does that make sense? You know? So I look at a ticket. If Summer's on that ticket, I know the next time he plans on looking at that ticket. So we're all assured we know.
Yeah.
we know the next time somebody's going to look at it. But if there's no future appointment on the ticket for anybody, then we have no idea what's going on.
These are all fair ask, you know, that's what everyone follow and that's the practice that we recommend for everyone. So it's not only in the APM AT, that's all over the ATVD here. Everyone follow the same practice. That's how the visual.
Yeah.
Yeah, so they don't seem to be following. My team is not only following it. I would say.
That's on me. I will get it fixed.
Okay.
And then I guess also you need access to ConnectWise. I mean, that would be, how do we do this? How do we do this? Do I give you a remote desktop, an APM remote desktop, and then you just log in once a day, you know, or when you have a chance? You know, that's one thing I would be glad to give you.
So I think, yeah.
Exactly, yeah, more visually, so yeah.
So...
Yeah, exactly.
so that you can always have a desktop in our environment. You know, the second thing is you like to have an API or something like that, we can look at that as well.
Yeah, okay, let me...
I see all the calendar and everything.
Right. Okay.
Another way is to where I had the APIs key, so whatever the board they work right, just like the read view access only on those, so where I have the centralized visibility, you know, what all tickets that they have, what all ticket their customer pending, what all ticket is scheduled, what is their calendar look like.
what all ticket are customer waiting rate. So I have those all centralized visibility from my side, which I can quickly check and find out what all tickets are pending. So.
Okay, so the API is going to be a secret key. You'll have a secret, right? That's how you get in, right?
That's probably gonna give me, yeah.
Right, so there's two public key and private key and the another thing is of course the connect wise your URL and that's what is the three things.
Well, I'm going to need an IP address to permit or, yeah, I mean, that's the only way. I have to give you an IP. You have to give me your source IP so I can allow it through a firewall.
Sort of, yeah.
You know, and I guess it could just be as, I mean, my only concern again is this, that if I give the source IP access, that's your entire IT by design site has access to that, that API. So that is, that is, that is a, that is a part of the.
problem with that API access because you come from the same IP address everybody else in that building does, right?
I think, yeah, but probably it's, yeah, we use the same VLAN and everything, yeah, but it's going to be on a secure side.
It's not that, yeah.
I, I, no, no, the problem is that there's hundreds of devices coming from the same IP address, so there's no way for me to restrict that access API access if that key is leaked, that you, you know, anyone else can get access to this API interface.
You know, the question becomes, well, you know, are you able to load, are you able to load?
I mean, I know, never mind.
I mean, I want to give you access to this API, but in the long run, I want to secure it better than this. The other part is I still want to give you a desktop login, and then you can log in and you can just, you know, see everything.
I think if, yeah, yeah, that will be good, and then.
Natively, you know, including the Team login, you know, the Outlook login, that type of thing. So you can just, you know, pop in, right? No?
I don't know.
Ohh.
So, let me whatever, yeah, yeah.
You need visibility. You need visibility.
You need visibility somehow.
So the source IP address, I guess, is going to be...
Well, I could probably see it right here on our side right now.
Do you have the source IP or do you want me to just confirm the source IP?
I'm not sure which one.
You have.
So I will have.
One 182.
Dot 73.17.52.
Or do you come from some other ITBD?
No, mine is different. 149.78.
Okay.
One 4978.
Go ahead.
Maybe because, yeah, that 192, 168, 149, 78.
Oh no, that's your private IP. I need your public IP.
But yeah, OK, yeah, it's probably let me see.
You go to ipaddress.com and you'll see your public IP.
I thought they happened different.
Now, which one do you have?
Oh, actually, I don't.
125, 63, 94, 42. That's my public.
Okay.
Okay, there's one 125.
63 and 94 42
Okay, so that's where I can get the API access.
And then also give you access to our cloud desktop.
So that you can load whatever.
And then you'll have more visibility to everything. But here's my, and that's fine, you're going to get all the visibility so you can do this without me having to always do it myself. Make sure that this, or trying, I mean, like you said, it's on you. So trying to get these guys to be following best practices correctly in ConnectWise, 100% across the board.
Kip.
You know, again, it becomes a bigger problem the more people we have, especially, and the more activity that we have.
Um...
so that we can all operate efficiently, which is what we need to do.
But I also was told, real quick, I just realized as I was looking at this.
Let me see.
I don't see a.
You guys need to turn on.
It looks like Safe's new system is currently powered off.
Yeah, hello, but yeah, the system is already set, so I already set it yesterday.
Yeah, it's currently off. I need to save the system turned on so that I can log into it.
I can check.
Or you can turn off the sleep settings. And you know, of course, I'll have to coordinate that. Because we're onboarding him tomorrow.
Yeah.
Okay, I...
No, yeah, definitely, yeah.
All right, let's hang up so we can do the, you know, rest before our QBR.
Yeah, right. So I think from my side, only the two pieces, the visibility, right? And second one is how are we going to measure these, right? You know now everyone skill set, what role responsibility everyone is, they are aligned, right? But how are we going to measure them if they are able to achieve those number or not what we have defined for staff?
for the next 30, 60, 90 days or same goes for summer inanimate, right? So they are working, but of course somehow someday we need to validate that they are doing what we are expecting to do them, right? So that's another piece probably if you can figure out how, what parameter do you think they are going to measure. So.
We'll define those scorecard parameters for them.
Yeah, I'll see if I, I mean, I've generated previous scorecards and I've sent them.
New scorecards, you know, will be good, but...
Yeah, I mean, obviously, yeah.
Yeah, maybe you have anything. We can share a few or maybe you have already defined some KPH for them. Yeah, or if not, then I think we have now different skill set people. So you probably can define a new one depending on their role.
Mhm.
Yeah, yep, yep, absolutely. You got it. Okay. We'll get that done.
Kour.
Aleks, I didn't want to interrupt the wonderful conversation by showing my face, so I kept in the background. How are you?
Kip.
Yeah.
Oh, really? Okay, so you heard all of my complaints. All right. Hang on, I got to change this lighting. This lighting is really bad, so I'm gonna...
Ohh.
Hi, Ketan. Good afternoon. Hello.
Hello?
There we go. I have this horrible shade I got to cover up. There we go. See, now I can, now I look a lot more normal. Okay.
Thank you, Amit.
Yeah, no, thank you. I just didn't want to interrupt the conversation. Yeah. So Aman, just a quick thing, right? We had two specific open actions open at our end. And I just want to make sure that if it is something that we are solving in next week or so, or is this something that we want to park for future?
So there are two things that I'm tracking as a part of to do Alex, I wanted to check. One is of course, access of ConnectWise for Aman to fetch the numbers and keep an eye on things. Not dedicated 100% doing it all the time for 8 hours, but of course randomly doing the QCs to make sure that.
those expectations are met. And the second action that we had as a to-do that we needed to agree on was the KPIs for each of the engineers so that you know that, you know, in which direction they were moving. So is this something that we can circle back next week?
to close these door probably would need some time to think over it.
Look.
I know what I want. I mean, I've explained it many times on the phone and it's not written anywhere. Well, it's been written down in a couple of different places. But
Okay.
Mm.
Yeah.
No, we remember that, yep.
I mean, is the quality of the interactions with our customers, the quality of the interactions of the... So, quantifying quality is always more difficult, but it is what is most important. So, the other thing is outcome-based measurements for L3s, L4 behavior.
Yeah, yeah.
not, you know, think about your schedules, how are your KPIs measured, right? I mean, it's like, you know, you know, the way we measure KPIs for more advanced personnel versus, you know, because we've got to push forward in that way in the mental, the mental thinking of what we're doing.
Yep.
Sure.
Mmh.
But yes, so outcome based behaviors based on, you know, job roles and requirements that are measured, for example, for somebody like safe who is coming on board.
Mhm.
I can't get his name right. Is it Safe South? I don't know. Seth? Seth, okay.
Save, save, yep.
Sam.
Seth, all right. So when Seth, Seth being, being, being informed, I've been informed as him being as an L4, you know, his responsibilities, right? Aligning there with architecting and designing and being responsible for
Safe will keep us safe.
You know, documentation, standard operating procedures, reporting.
Mhm.
you know, assuring our outcomes across our deliverables for backup and disaster recovery. Yeah. So that is his responsibility and his domain. And in fact, I actually thought of this morning, because the struggle was this couple of things during our calls, prior to hire, you know, prior to interview with Amit and you, Aman on the call.
Yep.
We discussed specifically, Seth, and how.
He is an L4 and more senior, right? And it was, and of course, I was told, oh, he was 20, and you know, this is all part of the bargaining process from the IT by design side. He has 20 years of experience. He's very senior, right? So we want to leverage those capabilities and that.
Mm.
you know, that he is being able to provide some senior leadership in the team. Yeah.
Yep, yep, yep.
You know, so that goes beyond just being an individual that's working on, you know, being backup disaster recovery and just backup disaster recovery products across the board that we have. And
What I also thought of this morning was his nature. I think it's going to be well for, well suited for our reporting across our platforms. You know, so you, you know, he'll be able to pull and design, put it together, the reports. We want to automate them as much as possible.
number one, but we need somebody that might be a point person for, you know, our cybersecurity reports as they come out of the systems and putting them in the right places and so on, because we want an account manager on our side or any side, doesn't matter. It's an account manager. It's not one of these five people, but it would be an account manager that's doing QBRs with our customers.
Yeah.
That's reviewing all the reports that have been coming across, you know, the systems, right?
Yep, yeah.
So how we measure each individual is going to relate to their job roles. And those roles will be qualitative and quantitative. There are those responsibilities will be qualitative and quantitative. And those will be measured. That's how we'll, I guess, call these KPI scorecards, right?
Of course, yep.
Mm.
Um...
For each of them.
The rudimentary stuff is of course going to continue to be very important. We talk about those response times, the, how do you, how we measure the ticket behavior, because the ticket behavior is the beginning, either the beginning of something good or beginning of something bad.
Yep.
You know, so if you start, if you start on the right track on the tickets, then they go on the right track, and if they, if they don't start in the right, you know what I'm saying, so...
Alright, rambled, I rambled on long enough.
No, no, it all makes sense, Alex. I'm thinking we have the QBR lined up for today and right after this, but it makes sense, Alex, that we move it to some other day, given that we already had a service call just now. And then a QBR after that, I think it's not the best use of your time.
Yeah.
So we could probably, you know, I can ask Rick to get in touch with you, find out when you're available and probably have it scheduled for some other day.
Yeah, look, that's fine. I think that's a great idea. I don't, I also don't exactly know what the cadence for a QBR will look like or who's going to be on the call because we have so many.
Patel.
So, QBR is so QBR is gonna be Rick from an onboarding manager, and for the hyper care period point of view, you will have Lee and myself and Aman, right? But of course, the discussions are more strategic in nature in terms of how things have been, where we can be better.
where we're focusing on, where do we align ourselves, and of course, moving away from a little bit of BAU to more wider topics. So yeah.
Okay. Yeah, why don't we go ahead and reschedule that for, you know, in a week, maybe.
Sure, sure. I'll get Rick to message you. Yeah, OK. I'll.
Or if you want to, if you want to push it out further, that's okay too. If you think it's better, it could either be.
June, July 1st or July 8th, you know.
Yeah, let me speak to Rick and I'll get him to connect with you to find out your availability and we can have it scheduled for some other day.
Okay.
Sounds good. Thank you.
Alright.
Great, I think we're good. Thank you, Aleks. So, thank you, Kevin. Good day. Take care. Bye.
Thank you.
Thank you, Aleks. Thank you, Karen. Thank you. Bye.
Bye.